[Música]
vamos a hablar de economía en directo
américa de france 24 ya está con
nosotros luis méndez zúrich louis vamos
entonces a comenzar este primer bloque
económico con el conflicto entre rusia y
ucrania porque el parlamento europeo
debatió un acuerdo para fortalecer las
reservas de gas un acuerdo que se
presenta un día después de que la
comisión europea presentará o anunciará
inversiones hasta 2030 como parte de ese
proceso para dejar la dependencia del
petróleo y el gas ruso pero este plan
que fue discutido en el parlamento
europeo prevé conseguir la mayor
cantidad de casas posible antes del
primero de noviembre del presente año de
acuerdo con el documento que fue
discutido en el parlamento europeo los
niveles mínimos de gas deberán situarse
en un 80% para noviembre de este año al
tiempo que entre otros puntos del
acuerdo está la medida para proteger
dichas reservas de interferencias
extranjeras esto
específicamente por lo ocurrido a
bulgaria y polonia que
vistosos con una menor cantidad de
suministro de gas por parte de la
empresa gazprom en resumen los estados
miembros de la unión europea deberán
trabajar para garantizar un suministro
entre 85 y 90 por ciento este último el
objetivo para los próximos años y así
proteger a los ciudadanos del bloque de
posibles choques de oferta el documento
señala que a partir del año 2023 los
estados miembros establecerán
trayectorias individuales de recarga con
la comisión adicionalmente el plan
contempla que aquellos estados del
bloque que no cuenten con capacidad de
almacenamiento subterráneo deberán
garantizar que al menos un 15 por ciento
de su consumo medio en los próximos
cinco años se ha almacenado en otro
estado miembro pero recordemos que
lograr el consenso para disminuir la
importación de gas y petróleo ruso ha
sido un largo debate que no logra el
consenso debido a la disparidad de
consumo dentro del bloque pues así
también se está presentando la discusión
para finalizar con la dependencia del
gas ruso por escuchemos qué fue lo que
el primer ministro italiano mario está
aquí respecto a la situación y las
estimaciones del gobierno indican que
podemos independizarnos del gas ruso en
la segunda mitad del año 2024 m24 es
todo blanco debemos mantener la presión
sobre rusia rusia atravesó los suns ya
través de las sanciones porque debemos
llevar a moscú a la mesa de
negociaciones tras negociar hacer las
cosas lo hice que ha manifestado el
gobierno ruso sobre esta situación por
el momento rusia confía que la
exportación de gas y petróleo se va a
mantener hacia europa por un tiempo
prolongado esto por diversas razones una
de ellas tiene que ver con el costo que
tendría para europa la importación de
gas y petróleo procedentes de otras
latitudes adicionalmente el kremlin ha
manifestado que europa necesita el nord
stream donde este gasoducto que enviaría
gas desde rusia hasta alemania y en
declaraciones que publica la agencia de
noticias efe el vice primer ministro
alexander novak indicó que europa
seguirá comprando su petróleo
a otros países pero la preocupación va
más allá de las fronteras europeas y se
extiende al mundo ante el temor de una
crisis alimentaria y ya la onu se
pronunció sobre este tema y el primer
ministro italiano pidió una iniciativa
conjunta para permitir la salida del
trigo ucr al ucraniano almacenado en los
puertos del sur del país entretanto
rusia ha manifestado que ello está
sujeto a una revisión de las sanciones
louis rápidamente vamos a nuestro
continente porque crece la preocupación
por la inflación en méxico este dato se
situó en 76 por ciento a tasa anual
durante el pasado media abril y por ello
el banco de méxico- trabaja para
controlarla así lo digo conocer el
subgobernador del banco central gerardo
esquivel quien indicó que el organismo
está haciendo lo necesario para
disminuir el actual ipc entre las
labores desarrolladas está el incremento
de la tasa de interés en más de 300
puntos bases que ya lo ha llevado
adelante y no se descartan medidas más
contundentes que pasa en líbano en
líbano hay problemas por la escasez de
gasolina y también para conseguir
en esto debido a la crisis económica que
atraviesa el país que ha limitado la
situación cambiaria y por ello los
proveedores no tienen como pagarle en
acceder a las divisas para poder
conseguir las materias primas y esto ha
generado largas colas tanto en las
estaciones de servicios como en los
sitios donde después de que el pan
express cifra el día tiene que ver en
este caso con el 13,9 que es el 3,9 por
ciento que es el dato de desempleo de
australia el más bajo desde 1974 en ese
país louis como siempre gracias por toda
la información es más adelante con más
economía nos vamos directo hasta madrid